les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 en este sexto mes
de guerra en Ucrania el mundo cultural
ucraniano sigue en lucha desde la
invasión rusa al menos 70 sitios
religiosos 13 museos 33 edificios
históricos y 17 monumentos han sido
destruidos según la UNESCO pero para
mantener a salvo el patrimonio que no se
puede trasladar o proteger de las bombas
nació el proyecto
es una aplicación móvil de escaneo que
convierte a cualquier Ucrania no en un
archivista digital capturando edificios
monumentos y otros elementos como
modelos 3D con su teléfono y los guarda
automáticamente en una base de datos una
documentación digital que transmite la
herencia cultural del país a las
generaciones futuras y que incluso
podría algún día ayudar a la
reconstrucción de lo destruido la
aplicación ha registrado más de 6000
descargas desde su creación en abril de
la artistas ucranianos algunos eligieron
combatir con sus instrumentos de música
para movilizar a la comunidad
internacional Esta es la convicción del
ucranean freedom Orquesta la orquesta de
la libertad de Ucrania bajo la batuta de
la directora Kevin lynnson este grupo
reúne lo mejor de los músicos ucranianos
algunos de ellos refugiados y otros
miembros de orquestas europeas fue
creado por iniciativa del Metropolitano
opera y del teatro Nacional de Polonia y
comenzó su gira de 12 fechas el 28 de
Julio en Varsovia ahora están
recorriendo Europa antes de concluir Al
otro lado del Atlántico en Nueva York y
Washington lugar de su concierto de
clausura el 20 de agosto
[Música]
y tal como los músicos de la orquesta de
la libertad de Ucrania 24 artistas
cirquenses del mismo país se presentaron
en el prestigioso festival de edimburgo
en Escocia a finales de febrero cuando
Rusia invadió ucraniala La Academia
municipal de artes escénicas
tuvo que repartir a sus 240 alumnos en
otras ciudades de Europa y también en
Australia y algunos de ellos encontraron
refugio en La tropa de Praga en
República Checa juntos a otros jóvenes
artistas chicos presentan ahora el
espectáculo Boom una efervescente
muestra de colaboración acrobática de
parte de una generación unida por la
guerra y el circo escuchamos lo que está
nueva creación representa para una de
estos artistas ucranianos
es un momento muy fuerte Porque cuando
acabamos de llegar a Praga fue súper
estresante para mí no entendía Dónde
estaba cuánto tiempo iba a pasar allá y
cada vez en nuestro espectáculo solo
intento transmitir todos mis
sentimientos y todas mis emociones de
este tiempo mostrarle al público en esta
primera parte de agosto del mundo
cultural dijo adiós a dos artistas que
dejaron sube ya al internacional era
conocido por sus experimentos con los
plisados pero también por los sencillos
jerseys negro de cuello vuelto que
llevaba el creador de Apple Steve Jobs
el 5 de agosto falleció a los 84 años el
diseñador de moda japonés y semillake
debido a un cáncer de hígado nacido en
1938 en Hiroshima ya que era un
sobreviviente de la bomba atómica que
Estados Unidos lanzó en su ciudad en
1945 su carrera en la moda abarcó más de
medio siglo y marcó la escena por su
originalidad e innovaciones con
materiales
[Música]
y ella se quedará para siempre como la
estrella del musical gris la cantante y
actriz australiano británica Olivia
Newton falleció a Los 73 años el 8 de
agosto por fuera de su carrera en el
cine el artista estaba yo 100 millones
de discos y ganó cuatro premios Grammy
los homenajes se sucedieron de sus fans
en el Hollywood Boulevard en Estados
Unidos al de ópera de cine en Australia
que se iluminó de luces rosa por su
inmensa contribución y concienciación
sobre el cáncer de mamá Ella misma
llevaba 30 años luchando contra la
enfermedad
[Música]
continuamos ahora con música para hablar
de los estrenos musicales de la semana
empezamos con el cantautor poppy francés
sliman y su nuevo tema miedos una
canción muy íntima en la que revela sus
angustias como artista pero también como
padre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por otro lado la banda de rock británica
un nuevo tema de su próximo disco
para octubre
[Música]
y la española Rosalía estreno el
videoclip de despecho con sonidos
Electro y merengue que sigue El Camino
del éxito de su último álbum moto mami
publicado a principios del año
[Música]
volver a tu lado Nos despedimos con la
cantautora estadounidense de Van Gogh y
su tema Witch una oda al poder de las
mujeres muchas gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y cuídense
[Música]
[Aplausos]